bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo sur les chaînes
parlementaires va refaire toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine en 45 minutes avec katia
ghislain bourque à dire bonjour michael
et de l'actualité cette semaine un début
de semaine marqué par le décès du
sénateur georges ermant d'ancien maire
de tours s'est donné la mort avant le
procès en correctionnelle
un geste très rare au politique dans une
lettre il dénonçait la chasse contre les
hommes politiques à qualité
parlementaire l'examen de la loi macron
a débuté au sénat dans une ambiance
assez animé la droite majoritaire à la
haute assemblée a supprimé quelques
mesures qu'elle juge contre-productives
le ministre emmanuel macron lui se dit
ouvert au dialogue
enfin à près de trois semaines de grève
à radio france au président mathieu
gallet a été auditionné à l'assemblée
nationale la ministre de la culture fait
appellera affirme que ce mouvement n'a
que trop duré et pour commenter cette
semaine notre invité est didier
guillaume bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
ce sénateur de la drôme alors avant de
dérouler la semaine je vous propose
c'est la tradition ici d'écouter l'avis
de certains de vos collègues sénateurs
mais aussi député réaction à chaud au
micro de lucie guillaumot et aurélien
idéal je crois qu'il réussit à mener son
groupe avec de la cohésion de l'équipe
et on voit bien que c'est un groupe qui
globalement en tout cas vu l'assemblée
nationale pour nous fonctionne bien et
guillaume est pour nous un bon
interlocuteur il est conciliant il est
diplomate et sourire
c'est à la fois un sénateur très
présents ici
puis je pense qu'il a
un ancrage solide dans son département
préféré et sur les sujets qui me
préoccupait agriculture biologique
restriction des pesticides et aux
allemands on a discuté fermement
dénoncer quelqu'un avec qui on a pu
dialoguer faire avancer un certain
nombre de choses il a une double
responsabilité à la fois d'assurer le
relais de l'action du gouvernement
et puis parallèlement de pouvoir mener
de beaux combats de réussi je crois une
bonne synthèse entre l'écoutent
nécessaire et le fait de tenir le cap ce
qui est également nécessaire
alors là ce qu'on dit c'est très sympa
aussi donne de la synthèse c'est pas
facile d'être l'homme de la synthèse 6
mai enfin être président d'un groupe
c'est deux choses c'est d'abord faire
vivre le groupe un groupe doit vivre
il doit se nourrir de la réflexion mais
c'est tout le monde il n'y a pas on doit
pas imposer les choses et c'est en est
on est plus intelligent à plusieurs que
seul et donc ce groupe socialiste du
sénat
moi je suis heureux depuis un an
d'assumer cette tâche parce que c'est un
travail collectif et ce groupe sans les
chips et aussi parfois faire preuve
d'autorité mais c'est les deux mais je
crois que les choses se passent pas trop
manassero du scan notre partenaire aussi
du figaro on viendra évidemment sur ses
1 an
vous avez aussi un certain franc-parler
jusqu'à et le garder pour autant lancer
une émission va commencer par la journée
du mardi qui a été rythmée par les
réactions et les hommages à la mort de
jean germain
jean jardin sénateur socialiste et
ancien maire de tours s'est donné la
mort le jour où devait s'ouvrir un
procès en correctionnelle
ni des mariages chinois l'a dénoncé jean
est la chasse aux hommes politiques
un choc pour les marins ne m'en terre
hommage dans l'hémicycle du sénat et des
paroles très fortes de son président
gérard larcher
on l'écoutait en fin de matinée nous
avons appris avec stupeur le décès de
notre collègue jean germain sénateurs
d'indre et loire
ils avaient décidé d'achever son chemin
et laisser un message à ses proches tous
tous oui nous sommes atterrés par cette
terrible nouvelle est encore sous le
coup de l'émotion
jean germain s'est sentie condamné avant
même d'être jugé par un système qui n'a
finalement jamais rien retenu depuis
pierre bérégovoy à des légumes j'imagine
tristesse parce que vous étiez très
proche de georges arbres mais aussi un
sentiment de colère ou la sortie de tous
les deux la part de tous les sénateurs
d'abord une pensée pour jean germain qui
était un exemple pour les sénateurs il
faisait peu de bruit il parlait peu mais
il parlait juste et à la commission des
finances alors vous aimez à la
commission des finances il était il
était vraiment considéré comme tel de
grande qualité et en même temps il a
fait un choix dramatique qu'il faut
qu'il faut respecter et moi j'aurai une
pensée pour lui pour sa famille pour ses
proches parce que même ce sentiment
dédramatiser domino si oui parce que
enfin j'ai eu l'occasion de lire enfin
la vie d'un homme
c'est plus fort que tout et aujourd'hui
moi ce que je veux ce que je veux
vraiment dire c'est que les hommes et
des femmes politiques doivent être
cuirassé quand on fait quand on s'engage
en politique il faut être solide
ils ne sont pas tous mais si il faut
être solide mais en même temps il faut
jamais oublier que derrière un homme
politique ou une femme politique
il ya un homme et une femme comme les
autres ou des papes et avec un coeur
avec un coeur avec des tripes avec tout
cela et voilà alors après c'est la vie
moi je veux mettre en cause personne
mais il a vécu cette période là très
douloureusement
il a fait un choix
c'est vraiment ça m'attriste un homme
honnête c'est un humaniste c'est un vrai
républicain lui il a su ce que c'est
l'ascenseur l'ascenseur républicain
entendu gérard larcher faire ce rapport
avec pierre bérégovoy est ce que ce
n'est pas allé à peut-être un petit peu
trop trop loin dans les exemples non
mais moi je veux pas commenter ce que
ali le président du sénat le seul à la
barre jeudi je dis simplement qu'il faut
que l'on regarde cette situation en face
pour la première fois dans l'histoire un
sénateur en exercice s'est suicidé voilà
et c'est une grande tristesse
alors on va revenir à l'actualité
parlementaire avec la loi macron qui est
de retour au sénat le texte qui vise à
lever les blocages de l'économie fait
beaucoup de bruit comme nous le raconte
quentin calmer dès les premières minutes
le ton est donné entre socialistes et
communistes quoi votre projet own
aborde-t-il pas la question centrale du
coût du capital
c'est à dire mais madame ricard arrêtez
de râler à chaque fois que l'on passe le
si vous voulez on peut prendre la porte
on peut sortir on a autre chose à faire
aussi
alors arrêtez de râler à chaque fois que
nous prononçons un mot qui n'est pas un
gros mot
voilà donc vous nous laissez comment les
communistes très nombreux en séance
dénonce la ligne économique des manuels
macron avec au total plus de 400 80
amendements déposés sur ce texte
il n'en fallait pas plus pour les
accuser de faire de l'obstruction nommé
480 amendements sur une loi qui compte
maintenant plus de 200 articles en quoi
on peut parler d'obstruction
ça fait une moyenne en gros de deux
amendements par article de la loi
nous disons une chose très très simple
et qui qui est notre unique ligne de
conduite nous l'avons dit avant les
élections pendant les élections après
les élections le rassemblement de la
gauche ne peut pas se faire sur une
politique comme la loi macro le montre
qui divise la gauche c'est aussi simple
que ça la gauche peut se rassembler et
nous le souhaitons
si elle est unie sur des projets qui
sont des projets de développement social
solidaire
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
c'est la droite sénatoriale qui entend
remanier le texte
emmanuel macron se retrouvent ainsi pris
entre deux feux on sentait pas trop
calculé entre les communistes et la
droite sylvain beaucoup sur mes gars
n'étaient pas avancer coûte que coûte en
séance au sénat pendant encore au moins
dix jours car les sénateurs communistes
l'ont déjà annoncé ils entendent prendre
leur temps et dénoncer la loi macron
article par article alors beaucoup de
tumulte sotexka avec d'un côté les
communistes de l'autre côté la majorité
de droite au sénat
et vous vous êtes ou dans tout ça est ce
que les socialistes sont pas un peu
isolé c'est tout nous nous sommes en
soutien au gouvernement en soutien à
cette loi croissance et activités et en
soutient emmanuel macron en soutien
total et un soutien total pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous pouvons tous faire
le même constat droite comme gauche avec
des sensibilités différentes
l'économie est en panne les entreprises
n'ont plus de marge
les salariés sont en déficit très loin
mais cette loi elle va très loin
pourquoi elle va très loin
mais pourquoi elle doit très loin mais
ça veut rien dire en virage libéral
savez moi je pense qu'il faut arrêter le
dogmatisme aujourd'hui à prague mathilde
oui la france ne peut plus permettre
dogmatisme ni de la part des communistes
des socialistes ou de la droite et de
l'ump
et quand je parle de dogmatisme quand on
regarde ce qu'a fait la droite à la et
le centre à l'assemblée nationale que
uniquement pour des raisons
politiciennes sur ordre et simplement du
patron de l'ump alors qu'il était
favorable avec la plupart des articles
de ce texte ont voté contre
ce n'est pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu
tout à l'heure le 110 m haies est ce que
le pc est fait de l'obstruction pc fait
pas plus d'obstruction que l'ump a pu en
faire vous que nous on a pu en faire que
lorsque nous tient dans l'opposition ils
affirment leur conviction elles sont
respectables
je les regrette mais aujourd'hui la
véritable obstruction à la limite c'est
l'ump c'est la commission spéciale qui a
vidé le texte de ces avancées et qui lui
pour le coup il fait prendre le virage
libéral parce que c'est la commission
spéciale qui fait un texte libéral dit
guillaume vous pariez dogmatiquement
vous rappelle quand à l'assemblée
nationale d'une partie des troupes
socialistes
on criait de tous les cris à l'assemblée
sur ce texte mais bien sûr je le
regrette
vous parlez des frondeurs aussi mais je
le regrette parce que c'est vers des
frondeurs
c'est pas normal que les choses se
passent dans son sens dans ce sens là
mais vous savez c'est parce que c'est
difficile que nous voulons rassembler le
plus possible les patrons de riz est là
et faire de la politique moreau
peut-être pas un ou deux mais je ne
crois pas ce qui compte ce qui compte
c'est de libérer l'économie c'est de
protéger les salariés et c'est de créer
de l'emploi
c'est ça l'enjeu de cette loi qui peut
être contre ces grands de ces annonces
la après le reste c'est du débat
politicien être pour ou contre le texte
on verra bien moi je regrette la sur le
sénat n'est pas plus avancé je le
regrette
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de vouloir
supprimer les 35 heures alors que la
droite pendant dix ans n'y a rien fait
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de vouloir
pousser en isère les seuils sociaux
c'est un frein on va tous supprimés
alors ces programmes alors qu'il en dise
oui mais programme pour 2017 s'était pas
suite 2007 et s'était pas celui de 2012
donc on verra quel est leur programme
ils venaient très facile de veulent une
vraie travail réforme par exemple du
contrat du cdi est-ce que vous pouvez
confirmer que dans la prochaine loi de
françois rebsamen qui aura lieu le 22
avril au conseil des ministres
on ne touchera pas au contrat de travail
je ne peux rien confirmer parce que je
ne sais pas ce qu'il y aura complètement
dans cette loi vsat sucrière j'en ai
parlé avec mon histoire s amène ce que
je vais vous dire c'est que nous nous
avons des principes pas de dogmatisme
mais des principes des valeurs et sur ce
cas précis je vais vous dire je vais
vous le dire ce qui compte c'est de
faire évoluer l'économie sans mettre à
mal les contrats de travail et sans
mettre à mal et pas toujours nécessaire
équilibre aussi à trouver débat bien sûr
oui mais c'est la grande différence
peut-être que nous avons avec la droite
c'est que eux ils se fichent
excusez moi l'expression des citoyens
des salariés ce qu'ils veulent c'est
l'économie d'économie l'économie pas moi
quand j'entends cette semaine la cgpme
la capeb et une partie du medef qui dit
les annonces du gouvernement qui ont été
faites mercredi les syndicats des
entreprises vont dans le bon sens et
bien voilà il faut aller plus loin sur
ce tour ne serait bonne garde dans ce
pays de se dire quand la patrie est en
jeu c'est l'économie dont il s'agît pas
la france est un grand pays
est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable de se
dire on va se rassembler là dessus c'est
ça l'enjeu alors nous avons des débats
sont rassemblés autour de la loi de
françois rebsamen du 22 avril pour un
nouveau projet je l'espère je l'espère
je l'espère nous verrons bien alors
didier guillaume il y avait aussi des
choses qui se sont passées à l'ump
puisqu'un accord a été trouvé pour
l'organisation des primaires qui auront
lieu en novembre 2016 les modalités sont
arrêtés pour l'instant nicolas sarkozy
n'a pas dévoilé sa candidature alors la
gauche a l'expérience des primaires est
ce que pour vous ça peut marcher aussi à
droite puisque c'est une première pour
se parler oui comme nous c'était une
première
la dernière fois je pense que c'est bien
c'est une élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui entre le peuple et les
élites entre les citoyens et la
politique entre les françaises et les
français et les hommes et les femmes
politiques
il ya plus qu'un gouffre il ya un a bis
il ya un an
c'est un autre monde et donc il faut
qu'une réhabilitation la politique
les uns et les autres en permettant s'il
alors peut-être on passera deux ans on
parlera du faux mais y compris par la
gouvernance et par la façon de faire et
aujourd'hui que des citoyens engagés à
droite non militants comme des citoyens
engagés à gauche non militants puissent
désigner leur candidat à la primaire
présidentielle
ça me semble logique à partir du moment
où on n'est pas en responsabilité qu'est
ce que vous répondez aux militants aux
adhérents du parti socialiste qu'on
entend beaucoup à gauche qui disent on
va aller voter pour à l'âge est fait
pour eux l'enragé à l'évidence non mais
ça n'a aucun sens aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on voit une primaire il faut
signer comme nous l'avions fait la
dernière fois charlie un engagement une
charte
comme quoi en portage hiver de droite
non non non tout ça c'est rien du tout
ça vous même pas la peine de s'y arrêter
allez on va passer cette forme retourner
au sénat la france a déroulé le tapis
rouge pour le président tunisien ils
étaient reçus d'une part à l'elysée par
françois hollande pour un dîner d'état
avant de prononcer un discours et c'est
assez rare un discours devant les
sénateurs dans l'hémicycle de la chambre
haute dit guillaume
c'est très rare un discours d'un
président à l'assemblée ou au sénat
évidemment à la chambre haute c'est très
rare et ça a été très très écouté il y
avait beaucoup de monde dans l'hémicycle
parce que vous me donnez un petit peu
votre santé il s'est dit c'est important
la tunisie
c'est un très grand moment un très grand
moment comme vous le dites c'est assez
rare qu'on supprime le roi d'espagne
devait le faire à l'assemblée mais avec
les événements ils ne la une ne l'a pas
fait c'était un bon moment parce que
c'est la première fois qu'un président
élu démocratiquement de tunisie vient en
france et s'exprime devant le parlement
français
c'est important parce que pour lutter
contre le terrorisme nous devons être
ensemble
c'est important parce qu'après ce qui
s'est passé dans l'eure dans leur pays
des attentats la marche du dimanche 29
mars où le président de la république
française étaient présents nous voulions
dire plusieurs choses
1 l'amitié entre nos deux pays deux des
relations fraternelles que nous devons
entretenir entre les peuples français et
les peuples tunisien et 3 que nous avons
à rapprocher nos politiques afin de
travailler ensemble
alors on va passer à mercredi didier
guillaume si vous voulez bien
avec manuel valls qui lancent ces grands
travaux de printemps sien on peut dire
le premier ministre qui a donc ouvert le
chantier de l'investissement et le mise
sur l'investissement pour faire revenir
la croissance en france en espérant que
les entreprises jouent le jeu
regardez ce sujet d'elisa bertolo mais
dix jours après la claque reçue lors des
élections départementales l'exécutif
réplique en proposant diverses mesures
en faveur de l'investissement
la principale la mise en place d'un
avantage fiscal pour les entreprises qui
acquerront des biens d'ici avril 2016
les montants investis pourront être
déduits de l'impôt sur les sociétés tous
les investissements industriels fait par
toutes les entreprises quelle que soit
leur secteur d'activité sont concernés
par cette mesure
c'est un effort là aussi sans précédent
de 2,5 milliards d'euros au bénéfice de
l'investissement industriel
autre volet de cet ensemble de mesures
l'investissement public
la bpi va augmenter ses prêts jusqu'à 8
milliards d'euros
un plan de travaux autoroutiers de 3,2
milliards d'euros d'investissements et
programmer les discussions avec les
sociétés d'autoroutes sont déjà entamés
elles se traduisent cdu
sion également par 500 millions
d'investissements supplémentaires dans
les infrastructures et les projets de
transports dont 300 millions à la fidh
sur trois ans sans hausse des tarifs de
péage en 2000 points concernant l'emploi
le premier ministre a rappelé les
réformes déjà engagées mise en place de
la prime d'activité réforme du dialogue
social et création d'un compte personnel
d'activité qui regroupera les comptes de
formation et de pénibilité
poursuivi également la mise en place du
pacte de responsabilité sur ce terrain
le compte n'y est pas l'effort est
insuffisant dans trop de branches
professionnelles avec l'annoncé de ces
mesures
manuel valls eux s'est livré à un numéro
d'équilibriste le premier ministre
marche sur un fil
il doit donner des gages à l'ailé gauche
du ps sans effrayer le monde de
l'entreprise
un numéro d'équilibriste aussi pour
manuel valls est pas facile sera pas
facile de mettre en oeuvre ses douze
travaux d'hercule
il va y arriver avec l'opposition des
frondeurs écoutez ça apparaît la vie la
vie politique ne tourne pas autour des
frondeurs autour de l'oeil gauche après
les élections départementales
mais ce qu'il aura les marges l'exécutif
le président de la république et le
premier ministre
entendu le message des urnes mais c'est
une des réponses ça n'a pas été que bâti
en trois jours cela si une des réponses
il fallait avancer qu avait dit françois
hollande dans la campagne des élections
présidentielles les trois premières
années seront difficiles
elles ont été difficiles et après si
nous avons des marges de manoeuvre nous
allons essayer de redistribuer alors on
est entré dans la phase de rodez strip
je crois nous avons d'abord beaucoup de
chance beaucoup de chance ce qu'il faut
appeler un chat un chat la reprise qui
vient de l'extérieur
la baisse du pétrole les taux d'intérêt
servi de ça dépend pas uniquement de
nous mais tant mieux pour les français
et des françaises tant mieux pour la
france est donc à partir de là les
français quelque part ils payent moins
cher leur essence ou diesel
donc il gagne un petit peu de pouvoir
d'achat pas assez mais ils gagnent un
petit peu la situation économique est
désastreuse nous en parlions il faut
redonner des marges de manoeuvre aux
entreprises
il faut libérer l'économie la loi macron
peut y contribuer et il faut surtout
investir comme votre votre reportage
la montre et et l'investissement public
les la distance l'investissement privé
est indispensable pour les collectivités
locales
il faut que les collectivités locales
investissent mais en même temps
l'équilibré des comptes fait quand je
veux pas revenir sur la baisse des
dotations qui a été annoncé par la
droite qui a été annoncé par la gauche
c'est surtout d'investissements privés
qui va peut-être qui permet de relancer
l'économie et qui est donc bonne pour
l'emploi mais est-ce que vous pensez que
les entreprises vont jouer le jeu
oui si vous permettez 70% de
l'investissement public en france peu
effet pas l'investissement français fait
par les collectivités locales
après l'investissement privé il faut que
les entreprises jouent le jeu et le
premier cela dit le compte n'y est pas
encore mais quand j'entends les petites
entreprises les pme celles que l'on
connaît dans une pme il n'y a pas de
différence entre le patron et le salarié
tout le monde a envie que la boîte
fonctionne parce que les enfants sont
les seuls non elles ne sont pas
pénalisés parce que justement dans les
annonces qui ont été faites ça va aller
dans le bon sens ils vont avoir des
marges pour pouvoir éventuellement et
paris ne joue pas le jeu qu'un gars tard
je toujours pas le jeu n'ont alors pas
assez ils ne jouent pas le jeu
il a un badge depuis des mois et des
mois à la boutonnière nous voulons créer
un million d'emplois
je les attends qu'est-ce que je pense
que le medef ce que vous leur dites
aujourd'hui au patron soyez des
patriotes
soyez une organisation patriotique aimer
la france et défendent et là je suis sûr
que c'est le cas alors comme il aime la
france et comme ils veulent la défendre
faut faire des efforts faut pas toujours
demander demandé demandé demander encore
ce qu'on pense que le lien avec deux
responsables ajouté par le pacte de
responsabilité quand même c'est en
direction des entreprises
ça nous a été reproché de dire vous
faites trop pour les apprécier côté
j'aime l'autre et pas assez pour les
eaux larribe et oui moi j'aime
l'entreprise bien sûr j'adore
l'entreprise parce que sans les
entreprises sans les patrons il n'y a
pas d'économie a pas de salarié donc
voilà il faut que les grandes
entreprises fassent un effort alors je
regarde exemple pourquoi selon vous les
patrons ne font-ils pas cet effort parce
qu'ils sont frileux parce qu'ils ont
peur de l'avenir parce qu'il leur faut
et c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
leur donner de la cohérence et de la
stabilité
on ne peut pas au gré d'un budget d'
année après année bouger les choses et
notamment sur le plan fiscal et
notamment sur le plan fiscal
oui
avez raison c'est la raison pour
laquelle le pacte de responsabilité et
maintenu les efforts pour baisser le
déficit sont maintenues pour baisser la
dette on ne bougera pas là dessus
maintenant dans ce qui a été annoncé par
le premier ministre il ya aussi des
nouveaux droits pour les salariés la
pénibilité
nous tiendrons elle est indispensable
mais pas une pénibilité
si on nous dit telle que ces faits là
par l'administration c'est une usine à
gaz
alors il faut il revenir notamment dans
l'agriculture que le secteur que je
connais un peu la pénibilité il faut la
mettre en place
mais telle qu'elle a été préparée ça ne
va pas je reviens de fauche angers avec
deux petites secondes sur emmanuel
macron il va aller plus loin plus vite
plus fort c'est lui qui tient la ligne
économiser maintenant été apprêté tout
cela c'est que les fonds macro mc ren
macron est un excellent ministre
il pousse dans une direction jeu nouvel
os mac rouge et a refusé
oui mais enverra des services on verra
tout ça il faut je pense qu'il faut
ralentir la vitesse médiatique de la
politique je pense les choses ont trop
vite
une phrase le matin qui essaie dans tous
les journaux ni l'âge et la terre oui
oui il faudrait faire l'éloge de la
lenteur
il ya une loi mâcon qui n'est pas voté
mais on va peut passer à une deuxième
loi macro mais qu'il avoue là est
peut-être le premier ministre lui a
répondu voilà il a donc aujourd'hui
réussissons la première loi macron dont
je suis un fervent soutien parce que je
pense qu'elle va déclencher va trouver
plein de choses
plein de choses maintenant il ya le
temps de la loi et surtout il ya le
temps des décrets je lui en ai parlé
récemment au ministre emmanuel macron je
lui dis attention
aujourd'hui les les français en leur
annonce des choses
ils veulent que ça aille vite mais nous
on fait une loi et que les décrit sort
parfois il faut 18 mois ou deux ans ce
n'est plus possible et rêverait donc il
faut ralentir le temps de prendre le
ralentir le temps médiatique des
annonces mais accélérer la mise en place
des décisions vous entendu je crois oui
bon ok on va continuer à passer au sénat
où une enquête un rapport sur les
enquêtes parlementaires sur les filières
djihadistes a été rendu au total 110
mesure où à ça en détail recruter
d'anciens djihadistes comme informateur
c'est l'une des 110 musée
présentés dans le rapport de la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur les
filières terroristes premier volet
internet
le nerf de la guerre du jihad médiatique
parmi les propositions
l'interdiction des cyber paradis ses
serveurs étrangers qui héberge les sites
jihadistes les démarches des internautes
seront aussi faciliter un clic suffira
pour dénoncer les messages et illicites
deuxième volet abordé les prisons autres
lieux propices à la radicalisation dans
le rapport
les sénateurs proposent de tripler les
effectifs du renseignement pénitentiaire
mais aussi isoler les individus
radicalisés
la commission a travaillé à huis clos
pendant plus de six mois mais aucun
chiffre sur le coût de ces mesures n'a
été publié voilà pour ce reportage de
géraldine bah voyons
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé sur tv5
là on peut vraiment constaté que la
france a pris beaucoup de retard
oui la france a pris du retard la france
a pris du retard parce que ya pas eu de
créations de postes parce qu'il ya eu
aussi la rgpp et je veux pas faire de la
polémique mais arborant réduire les le
nom de vétérinaires qu'on les remplace
pas d'un certain secteur dans les
tribunaux dans la justice dans la police
et dans la défense et dans le
renseignement et bien les choses peuvent
pas bien fonctionné donc là une prise de
conscience là encore il ya ce rapport
qui a été fait il ya la loi
renseignement qui va venir au sénat dont
je pense qu'elle pourrait être quasi
unanime nous ne sommes pas favorables à
un patriot act à la française ce que je
pense la réponse des états unis après le
11 septembre n'est pas forcément la
bonne mais en même temps l'angélisme
ça suffit l'angélisme ça suffit il faut
prendre des décisions fortes qui
permette à la france et à ses services
de ravoir du renseignement et de
rattraper le retard par des lunettes les
wc un texte oui j'espère que j'espère
qu'il le sera pour ces sujets il faut
être unanimes ce qui s'est passé à tv5
attaque majeure ça fait peur à nos
concitoyens moi j'ai eu beaucoup de
messages d'amis de la drôme qui me
disent m'enfin on peut s'en prendre une
telle est donc ça veut dire qu'on ne
maîtrise plus rien il faut il faut
rassurer c'est pour ça que jeudi dernier
aux questions d'actualité au
gouvernement nous avons posé une
question à bernard cazeneuve pour qu'il
nous dise des choses là dessus mais on
sait qu'avec l'argent kds ils peuvent
acheter beaucoup de choses donc à nous
de répondre à cela de façon forte et moi
j'ai confiance au gouvernement chef de
l'état et à bernard que genève qui fait
preuve quand même de solidité à son
poste alors va changer de sujet on va
parler du blocage à radio france
l'entreprise publique connaît la plus
grande la plus longue grève de son
histoire son président mathieu gallet a
été auditionné ce mercredi par la
représentation nationale
il est un peu passée sous le feu roulant
des questions des députés résumé avec
rim benameur après plus de vingt jours
de grève à radio france le conflit
s'enlise lors d'un cce extraordinaire
mathieu gallet son président très
contesté devait présenter son plan
stratégique comprenant 300 suppressions
de postes mais les syndicats grévistes
ont suspendu la réunion peu après son
début et lu une déclaration où il accuse
la direction d'avoir parié sur le
pourrissement du conflit il vote la
poursuite de la grève les syndicats
estiment donc qu'ils n'ont plus
d'interlocuteur il demande à fleur
pellerin de nommer un médiateur
je prendrai mes responsabilités si je
l'avais dit la semaine dernière et donc
cela veut dire très concrètement que je
recevrai les parties prenantes très
rapidement et que très rapidement
également je ferai connaître les
décisions que je prendrais pour renouer
le dialogue social
la journée aura été très compliqué pour
mathieu gallet déjà chahuté par les
députés lors d'une audition à
l'assemblée nationale quelques heures
plus tôt mais il affiche sa
détermination
revenons au projet revenons à nos atouts
à ce qu'on sait faire rire de la radio
moi j'ai pas prévu de charge et radio
france à autre chose qu'un groupe de
radio c'est dans ce sens là on doit
aller parce que c'est le sens de notre
mission et c'est ça que je porterai j'ai
encore quatre ans de mandat et je peux
vous dire pendant quatre ans je ne
lâcherai rien par rapport à ses
convictions le csa qui a nommé mathieu
gallet en mai dernier donnons lui aussi
une médiation pour mettre fin à cette
grève la plus longue de l'histoire du
groupe
voilà des syndicats radicaliser une
direction a faibli en état hésitant et
finalement fleur pellerin labellise qui
décide de nommer un médiateur
est ce que pour vous c'est
la bonne solution dès que les choses
vont mal on en a marre médiateur est ce
que l'état ne fuit pas quelque part ces
responsables comment un état hésitant
enfin les époques en changer donc il
sait pas le sel c'est pas le président
de la république il prit ministre qui
dirige radio france pas plus que france
télévisions le csa qui csa qui n'aurait
plus besoin de la république qui nommer
ses amis
donc là il ya aujourd'hui des tas doit
agir aujourd'hui aujourd'hui manière
stop
oui parce que la situation dans laquelle
elle était insupportable trois semaines
de grève dans une dans une chaîne
publique ce n'est pas cher si on dit
stop
je n'ai pas posé pour dire stop le
gouvernement a nommé un médiateur
c'est pas au gouvernement de dire
directement ce qu'il faut faire ça
serait de l'ingérence
ce n'est pas c'est pas notre conception
de du service public de l'audiovisuel
le médiateur va faire ce qu'il a à faire
nommer par là par fleur pellerin par le
gouvernement et puis il faut qu'on nous
en sortions ça ne peut pas durer
il n'y a pas eu assez de voir comment il
n'y a pas eu assez de dialogue il faut
que monsieur galets vour discute plus
avec les syndicats les organismes le fil
du dialogue non non c'est jamais fini ce
n'est jamais fini le fil du dialogue le
médiateur à faire son travail
après il faut essayer de duras bibeau
chipie le csa prendre les décisions
qu'il devra apprendre à dire je n'en
sais rien qu'il aura à prendre
est-ce que ce que je veux silence en
absence d bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
dans cette situation là rien n'a
vraiment fonctionné
rien n'a vraiment fonctionné parce que
trois semaines de grève sans arriver à
discuter a avancé à faire des petits pas
armand n'étant quasiment au même endroit
vingt-deux jours après que au début du
conflit ce n'est pas possible
il peut encore dire non mais selon vous
trois semaines de quasi pas encore
président et un accord crédible
il ya eu deux de ses salariés la
crédibilité je n'en sais rien la vraie
crédibilité c'est que radio france
reprenne l'antenne que les choses
redémarrent une fois qu'elles ont
redémarré que l'on voit en fonction du
cas des médiateurs comment les choses
pour entamant cette île est pas cassé
j'espère que non ça serait dramatique
mais vous savez faire très attention
parce que radio france dans quelques
jours ou quelques semaines vision stay
or à france télévisions innovantes à
nous avons nous
on nous dans ce pays un service public
de la radio de l'audiovisuel qui est
important à soutenir très important et
on sait que vu les budgets c'est c'est
difficile donc attention à ne pas casser
l'outil et il faut que les présidents de
ces chaînes de france télévisions comme
de de radio france s'aperçoive de ce
qu'ils ont dans les mains de ce qu'il
dirige quoi pas parler de politique
et on va parler du front national prévu
certainement que c'est la guerre ouverte
au front national la guerre entre le
père et la fille s'est résumée par
pauline darbes cette image celle d'une
complicité entre un père et sa fille est
trompeuse
la rupture est consommée au coeur de la
polémique
l'interview de jean marie le pen à
l'aide de madère rivarol un journal
d'extrême droite considéré comme hostile
à marine le pen
le président d'honneur du fn critique
les choix politiques de sa fille
stigmatise manuel valls sur sa
nationalité et va jusqu'à prendre la
défense de pétain la riposte est
cinglante
marine le pen parle de suicide politique
et elles n'ont ce qu'elle s'opposera à
la candidature de son père aux élections
régionales en paca pour florian
philippot la rupture est désormais
totale et définitive est en totale
contradiction et sur tous les sujets
d'ailleurs excusé est ce que pense le
front national marine le pen est donc le
front va prendre ses responsabilités si
les cadres du parti tire à boulet rouge
les fidèles de jean marie le pen préfère
rester silencieux le sénateur roger
karoutchi n'est pas étonné c'est un
règlement de comptes à ok corral un peu
prévisibles le père qui lui se sent des
saisies de tout pouvoir sans que c'est
sa fille qui met les siens et que les
siens et qui dit comment comment et donc
il va dans la provocation
pour ce chercheur spécialiste du fn la
stratégie du patriarche est clair le
veut vraisemblablement se poser comme un
gardien du temple
il s'agit avant tout d'un rappel
identitaire de mémoire de ce qu'a été le
front national et ne lit n'est pas
contre la stratégie de marine le pen
mais
il estime vraisemblement qu'elle ne doit
pas conduire à effacer ce qu'ils
considéraient comme l'identité profonde
du front national jean marie le pen
sera-t-il exclu de sa fonction de
président d'honneur
le fn doit réunir le 17 avril un bureau
politique
on a entendu tous les commentaires
possibles et imaginables
on parle d'explosion du front national
vous êtes d'accord je m'en fiche je m'en
fiche totale par un problème non c'est
pas mon problème je suis dis simplement
que jean marie le pen les propos qu'il a
tenus ces derniers jours ses 20 ans qui
les tient et il n'avait pas bougé tous
ceux qui sortent du bois aujourd'hui
parce qu'il est peut-être plus âgés
alors il parle toujours de théories du
complot je vais pas rentrer là dedans
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de différences mises à part sur
ses phrases il n'y a aucune différence
entre le grand père la fille et la
petite fille là
l'orientation politique du front
national c'est la même depuis depuis des
années elle n'a pas changé
marine le pen veut ripoliné la grande
différence entre elle et son père c'est
que le père ne voulait pas accéder au
pouvoir
ce qui l'intéressé c'est nos positions
et la fille a l'ambition d'aller au
pouvoir donc elle rit pauline elle met
un peu de la peinture du cache-misère
lui c'est les mêmes orientations le
faire absent ça permet peut-être aussi à
certains qui hésitaient à aller au front
national d aller très franchement de
redevenir un parti plus fréquentable non
mais le prix national est un parti qui
existe c'est un parti qui a le droit de
se présenter aux élections
donc il est comme les autres mais en
même temps c'est pas un parti
républicain
regardez ce qu'ils disent la xénophobie
on va renvoyer qui l'autre côté de la
méditerranée à partir et a délégué la
république mais bien bien bien sûr si
sévère puisqu'il existe un plan mais
bien sûr mais c'est pour ça que nous
nous devons changer notre façon de faire
de la politique parce qu'aujourd'hui
quel est le coût de la france quel est
le sentiment des français c'est que le
sentiment de repli sur soi le sentiment
d'un individualisme a pris le pas sur
l'appartenance à la nation
la haine de l'autre ce que fait entre en
ce moment nicolas sarkozy sur
l'assistanat qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est pour tirer des réflexes par
rapport à l'électorat du front national
nous devons parler clair et faire se
réapproprier ses idées ses valeurs mais
tu es part il faut il faut mettre ces
valeurs en avant tout le temps la valeur
travail
elle est
pas de droite ou de gauche c'est une
valeur essentielle la protection c'est
nous qui l'avons et s'ils font national
par malheur accéder au pouvoir
eh bien on verrait tout ce qui s'en
suivrait la sortie de l'europe la sortie
de l'euro la débandade économie alors je
vais pas dire ça va être le pire je veux
simplement que dire que le front
national pour nous c'est un adversaire
est rédhibitoire par les clients très
remuant contrairement à nicolas sarkozy
qui lui se sert de nous pour faire
barrage au front national mais se sert
du front national pour nous battre
et si on parlait un petit peu votre
parti et a conclu préparer fait déjà dit
allez on y croit
nous sommes donc à la veille des dépôts
d'émotion au vu du congrès du parti
socialiste qui se tiendra en jeu chacun
choisit son corps et au west tout cela
en images
après des semaines de tractations l'ailé
gauche du ps s'est mise d'accord c'est
christian paul député socialiste de la
nièvre qui mènera la motion des
frondeurs les proches de martine aubry
eux maintiennent le suspense
ils seraient tentés de rejoindre la
motion de jean christophe cambadélis
ils demandent au gouvernement d'
infléchir sa politique économique manuel
valls leur a donné des gages avec ses
annonces sur l'investissement les choses
semblent donc entendue sauf coup de
théâtre on a toujours dit que toutes les
options restaient ouvertes etc on se
déterminera en fonction de l'intérêt du
pays
c'est à dire des politiques qui sont
menées pour l'ailé droite du ps
le rassemblement est déjà acquis avec
martine aubry avec les réformateurs
je pense que
on peut tout à fait se rassembler
maintenant il y aura aussi une
confrontation dans ce congrès dernière
motion en vue du congrès celle du
courant cohérence socialiste animé par
karine berger critiques envers le
gouvernement mais pas frondeuse
alors avant de revenir à votre parti du
parti socialiste pour matière au du scan
notre partenaire du figaro qui va vous
interroger dans quelques secondes
mais avant la évidemment parlé un petit
peu du parti socialiste vous voyez
comment ce congrès ce que c'est gagné
d'avancé
si jamais gagné d'avancé mais la partie
logiquement c'est plutôt bien parti
je crois qu'il faut qu'il est là la
motion menée par vous faites partie des
harmonies ce oui alors ça tout ça les
téléspectateurs se faire cruellement de
notre notre business de systèmes ça il
faut dire les choses mais enfin on a un
congrès est ce qu'il tombe au moment
j'en sais rien
alors que nous voulons redresser la
france alors que nous voulons faire
évoluer l'économie
les socialistes vont se retrouver
pendant deux mois dans un débat interne
il faut t'y pas c'est ce que je veux
dire c'est que l'enjeu est clair il faut
un parti socialiste qui soutiennent
claire clairement le gouvernement qui
puisse infléchir un certain nombre de
choses mais pas un parti socialiste dans
l'opposition
enfin quand je vois la face au leinster
bien sûr quand je vois que ce sont les
frondeurs ceux qui ont mis à mal le
gouvernement depuis des mois qui ont été
les plus grands opposants à l'assemblée
nationale qui n'ont pas voté des budgets
qui n'ont pas voté le pacte de stabilité
et qui nous ont contraints à faire le
49-3 sur l'album accroc
quand je vois que sont les frondeurs qui
dirige cette motion je pense que c'est
quand même grave donc votre partie
coupée en deux environ 2
il y aura un vote on verra on verra ce
que seront les îles et pas du tout pour
l'instant il ya quand même de yaël goosz
et ça a toujours été le cas
katz a toujours été le cas aux portes
mais oui a toujours eu les courants
d'émotion ray moi j'en appelais logo
rassemblement et à l'unité forcément
parce que pendant un an
y'avait pas de droite elle était empêtré
et donc l'opposition au gouvernement
c'était les frondeurs mais moi je ne
veux pas ça le parti socialiste doit
être en phase avec le gouvernement il
doit le pousser tous derrière manuel
tous derrière le chef de l'état tous
derrière tout le monde
féminines mais bien sûr enfin ça
rimerait à quoi que les ministres ne
fasse pas le congrès les ministres sont
la cia nous nous soutenons le
gouvernement et j'espère que la motion
de de christian paul soutiendra le
gouvernement aussi ce sera l'enjeu du
congrès je reviens petit peu tout ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure parce que
vous en avez parlé et je voudrais
revenir un petit peu vous avez dit pas
sûr que cette date sur la meilleure pour
avant le congrès je ne trompe pas quand
vous avouer je voudrais pas non mais
j'aurais viennent jamais de bundle trop
tard parce mais non mais c'est pas ça
c'est parce que nous sommes nous sommes
en train de mettre en place des lois
pour faire bouger la france est à ce
moment là nous nous allons être en
conclave dans un congrès bon et je pense
que les français vont regarder ça de
façon un peu bizarroïdes qu'il aurait
fallu les calmer
je n'en sais rien il a lieu là donc on
va on va le tenir
s'il faut qu'il se passe le mieux
possible mais il faut surtout il faut
surtout si je peux me permettre dernier
mot que le congrès des socialistes ce ne
soit pas les socialistes aux socialistes
mais les socialistes parlent de france 2
n'a pas parlé mais chrétien je sais que
vous pouvez d'envié d'en parler martine
aubry d'un mot martine aubry qu'est ce
qu'elle peut faire martine aubry si elle
ne vous rejoint pas au ciel vous rejoins
c'est la grande gagnante ce sera mais il
n'y a pas de gagnants et de perdants
nous nous voulons rassembler tout le
monde et martine aubry à sa place dans
la motion majoritaire ça en asie de se
dire mais non mais parce que c'est ça a
été encore légumes sa médiatique et tout
ça c'est le jeu mais oui ça n'a pas
d'importance
elles jouent le jeu elles jouent le jeu
nous avons besoin d'avancer
nous avons besoin de faire évoluer la
politique et tout le monde doit
travailler alors on va quitter le ps
didier guilleret mais puisqu'on va
acquérir notre partenaire du figaro joue
pour un petit décryptage de l'actualité
politique
c'est la loupe du scan
et mathilde de sirop est donc dans la
place vous revenez sur la polémique de
la semaine
oui didier on a encore beaucoup parler
de laïcité cette semaine comme vous
savez avec cette affiche de la ratp et
la mention des chrétiens d'orient la
ratp s'est finalement ravisé avec
l'indignation des politiques on a
entendu dans le même temps cette
proposition du secrétaire d'état thierry
mandon qui voudraient plus de mosquées
alors vous dit guillaume vous défendez
la laïcité
vous dites même laïcards qu'est ce que
vous en pensez qu est ce que ça vous
inspire
mais la ra la ratp a fait une grosse
bêtise enfin y'a pas lieu à polémiquer
sur quelle sera un sujet comme ça moi je
regrette que ce soit passé comme ça le
premier ministre a sifflé la fin de la
récréation et les choses sont rentrées
dans l'ordre
il faut pas aller dans un sens ou dans
l'autre c'est comme quand bernard acoyer
dès qu'il ne faut pas que le que
l'assemblée nationale siège le vendredi
saint mais dans quelles en sont les
vrais débuts dans quel monde sommes-nous
enfin ça ça va pas tout cela donc la
laïcité ça doit être une valeur que nous
devons toujours portait un drapeau qui
claquent au vent de la république c'est
cela il n'ya pas lui mettre un adjectif
laïcité ouverte et site est fermé ceci
cela la laïcité c'est le respect de tous
et donc les affiches pour le cancer qui
est la mention chrétiens d'orient ça ne
pose aucun problème
c'est un manque de un manque de
discernement après ce n'est pas à nous
ce n'est pas la sphère publique de dire
s'il faut construire des mosquées des
églises ou je ne sais pas je ne sais
trop quoi
mais il faut que nous repensions cela
moi je ne suis pas favorable depuis très
longtemps à ce que l'argent public serve
à financer des lieux de culte parce que
la loi de 1905
ce n'est pas cela en même temps il ya
des situations il faut sortir nous
l'avions mis depuis des années il faut
sortir l'islam des caves
parce que si nous voulons un islam
ouvert un islam l'islam est une belle
religion une religion formidable mais
pour que ces gens puissent pratiquer
leur religion en toute tranquillité
mathilde aux fêtes d'anniversaire
oui c'est bientôt votre anniversaire
didier guillaume bientôt un an à la tête
du groupe socialiste au sénat
alors vous avez vécu la bascule à droite
du sénat en septembre
est-ce que c'est plus facile de diriger
un groupe qui est dans la majorité ou
dans l'opposition c'est pareil c'est pas
mal et les socialistes et jean tu vois
comme ça
oui oui oui bon moi ça fait un an
celui-là je suis très très heureux
d'avoir la confiance de mes amis mais
c'est pas le sujet nous avons fait
quelques mois dans la dans la majorité
c'était très compliqué il vous a pas
échappé que la majorité au sénat n'était
pas toujours là bon là nous sommes
maintenant dans l'opposition et nous
nous regroupons pour défendre nos
convictions pour soutenir le
gouvernement
oui alors je vais vous parler un petit
peu des frondeurs encore imaginez vous
un instant dans la peau de bruno le roux
le président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
est-ce que vous à sa place vous auriez
pris des sanctions contre les fraudeurs
non mais écoutez bruno le roux très bon
président de groupe
il vit des situations parfois un peu
difficile dans ce qui est des textes
avec les frondeurs ce n'est pas le sujet
ce n'est vraiment pas le sujet assez
c'est vrai mais on ne convainc pas par
des sanctions on convainc par des idées
et aujourd'hui on voit bien que tant
qu'il y'aura on n'aura pas passé le
congrès du parti socialiste ait repris y
aura quand même des postures interviews
ces derniers mois sur les
départementales votre département la
drôme est passé à droite oui vous ne
vous avez refusé de vous représenter une
à la tête du conseil général
est ce que vous regrettez non non
j'avais fait un choix personnel
moi je suis pour trois mandats
consécutifs maximum
j'ai voté la loi sur le cumul des
mandats limitant le cumul des mandats je
me la suis appliqué ce sera le mot de la
fin était l'invité de merci à vous hebdo
et on se retrouve bien évidemment la
semaine prochaine même lieu même heure
bonne semaine